if your reserve parachute doesn't work
the procedure is
basically you're going to hand salute
the world and you're going to hit the
dirt because you're going to die
hi this is jocko willink and this is the
[Music]
breakdown
[Music]
this is the movie navy seals
what's our altitude it's about 30 000.
that's six miles up
halo jump is high altitude low opening
you skydive through the radar so they
don't see you you go at such a high
altitude that they can't pick you up and
then you open your parachute at a low
altitude
where the radar isn't effective you'd be
using this if you wanted to go somewhere
and you didn't want anyone to know you
were there
it allows you to get in without being
detected halo jumping is fun
so if you're just training you're going
to have a good time if it's night combat
equipment halo jump
there's going to be a little bit more
intensity in the situation but if it's
just a
fun free fall that you're doing during
the day for good times
everyone will have a good attitude and
be having fun with it let's go back
loading magazines that's pretty
unrealistic you should have your gear
prepped prior to the
jump procedures 45 minutes at the beach
landing side
that's one thing they usually miss in
military movies is in a helicopter or an
aircraft it's so loud in there you can't
just be having a normal conversation
you've got to yell and scream at each
other
or write stuff down or use hand and arm
signals how much time 30 seconds means
you're 30 seconds from
going out this right here super complex
six minutes
if you have a long flight sure somebody
might be reading a book why not almost
every mission that i went on was
in a vehicle and in a vehicle we weren't
reading books because
when you're in a vehicle outside the
wire then you have to be paying
attention
for ambushes and whatnot outside the
wire just means
wherever you're stationed you have a
perimeter and the perimeter's got you
know a wall around it there's barbed
wire on the wall
barbed wire so therefore we're inside
the wire
and then the enemy is outside the wire
you know c-130 is the
actual transport plane that the military
used for
decades and now we have newer planes but
i think this film is from 1990
and it's probably pretty accurate that a
c-130 would be used the c in c-130
is designated as a cargo plane people
think that it's
bad flying in a cargo plane it's
actually awesome and people string up
hammocks and put down ground pads and
get in sleeping bags and it's like time
travel because you just go to sleep and
you wake up and you're at your
destination i actually enjoyed
traveling in cargo plants good times let
me fast forward a bit
when you jump out of an airplane you're
going to have an altimeter which is
going to tell you what your altitude is
you're gonna have a parachute and in
this particular one where they're
jumping
above 13 000 feet you need oxygen so
they have oxygen on it's just an oxygen
mask they're going to depressurize the
cabin so they can open up and
that way you're not breathing that thin
air that's why they need to put those
oxygen masks
on jesus dame
it doesn't look good i wouldn't jump it
if i were you
what's happening right there is actually
pretty realistic having your buddy
check out your equipment in the seal
teams and really in all branches of the
military you rely on each other to make
sure you're safe
the guy's checking the other person's
pins on his rig to make sure that
they're going to deploy his parachute
properly
and then he's actually messing with him
which is pretty normal too if you know
someone's scared of parachuting
then he's gonna get messed with a little
bit more never let anyone know that
you're scared of anything
just keep it to yourself someone on the
team is called a jump master
and that person is actually checking the
navigation and checking the position
and making sure that we're exiting the
aircraft at the right point there's an
actual school that you go
to to become a jump master and inside a
platoon
of 16 guys there'd probably be two or
three jump masters that could run a jump
three two one that's real
yep the light system where it's a red
light that means
hold and when that light turns green
that's the signal to go
you gotta remember that that aircraft's
moving very fast so if someone jumps
then you wait five seconds
you're gonna be too far separated so
yeah you go out in a very tight group
you stay close for a while
once you get close to opening then you
separate a little bit
because yeah obviously once your
parachutes are open you don't want
people hitting each other
so for a jump like this you get to 2 500
feet you're checking your altimeter the
whole way down
you get a little separation from the
other members of the team this is your
signal it's called waving
so everyone knows that you're about to
pull your parachute and then you look in
at your rip cord
when you pull your rip cord out your
parachute deploys
so what you should feel when you pull
your rip cord is a little bit of a delay
and then something called the pilot
chute it's a spring-loaded small
parachute that thing jumps off your back
and it grabs air and then that's what
pulls out the rest of your parachute
you're all of a sudden
pulled you know it's like coming to an
abrupt stop in the air so that's what
it's supposed to feel like
but as you can see in this particular
situation this guy isn't going to feel a
very hard shock because he's having a
malfunction
[Music]
there's a bunch of different things that
can go wrong with a parachute i had one
malfunction in my career
see that there's a little square there
right right by his hands above his hands
it's called the slider and it actually
comes down it's up with the parachute
and as your parachute opens up it slides
down towards the base
and sometimes that can get hung up it's
called a hung slider and what it does is
that that small
square of fabric keeps the whole
parachute stuck together
that's what i had and my parachute was
just not opening what do you do when
your parachute doesn't open you follow
the procedures you know we train really
hard to know what the procedures are
there's some things that you can do some
procedures you can do to try and get to
clear
that malfunction so in my case i was
pulling on the risers to see if i could
get that slider loose to start to come
down it wasn't working
i'm checking my altimeter because at
1900 feet i said okay
this parachute isn't going to work and
so then you go through your cutaway
procedures
you arch to get your body position
correct you look at your
cutaway it's called a cutaway pillow you
grab it you pull that
and then you look at your reserve handle
you grab it you pull that the first one
cuts away your main parachute
so that it's not going to interfere with
anything and there's actually a
mechanism
that when you cut away your main
parachute it starts to deploy your
reserve parachute sometimes you don't
even need to pull the rep cord hopefully
you get a good solid shoot at that point
which
i'm sitting here today which means my
reserve parachute worked thankfully
there's been guys that have survived
what's called a partial malfunction
meaning that they have
some fabric up above them that's slowing
them down a little bit
but if you're going terminal velocity
and you hit the ocean the
ground doesn't really matter you're
you're dead all right let me play that
this is a partial malfunction so you can
see some of his parachute is open
now if you hit the ground with that type
of parachute it's going to be a real
problem i mean you're going to be
severely injured
but if you hit the water with that kind
of parachute it's i mean
you have a chance so there's a cutaway
and there is his reserve
barely opens when he hits the water get
a decent amount of cloth over his head
once you hit the water now you need to
assemble your crew and normally you'd be
jumping out with a boat
i think in this particular scene they
commence immediately on a dive
which is which is not very realistic
the distance that you'd have to travel
on the dive if you were to parachute in
you'd have to be at least
over the horizon which is 12 nautical
miles out to sea
you're not going to be able to dive 12
nautical miles there's no
human diver that could do that so that's
pretty unrealistic
this is active valor blackbeard
loud and clear standing by on this fit i
think what they're trying to simulate
here is something called a rigid hole
inflatable boat which is a kind of
common craft used in the seal teams it's
actually used for these type of
situations that they're showing right
now
in this movie which is moving up a
riverway where you have a little bit
more
latitude to use a bigger craft listen to
your location
15 mics just stands for minutes mics is
minutes it's kind of interchangeable
so the things on their helmet this guy's
got an actual light i don't know why
he's got it pointing backwards but he's
got a normal
camping headlight and then the other
thing that they've got is a night vision
mount but there's no night vision on
their
gear right now well we move underwater a
lot but we do it while we're diving
so appearing like that is
not very realistic one of the hardest
things about maintaining weapon is
bringing it
through the water especially in the
ocean this is regular fresh water so
it's going to be a little bit easier
it's still
when you get out of the water you have
to make sure that the barrel is clear
and you have to drain the water out of
the weapon
just because you're in the seal teams
does not mean that you are a sniper
sniper is a specialized school that guys
go to and there's a bunch of different
schools
you could be a communications expert you
could be a medic you could be
what's called a breacher where you work
explosives to open doors
i was a communicator so i went to a
communication school i went to a ton of
other schools on top of that
but as far as major designations of
scrolls i didn't go to sniper and i
wasn't a breacher either
freeze this frame the reason you haven't
seen a drone like this before is because
in terms of drone technology this is
ancient
these were very difficult to fly i mean
nowadays they have little
quadcopter drones that a five-year-old
could fly around if they wanted to
these were a lot harder to fly you had
to be a little bit more of a pilot to
make them work it didn't take very long
for these types of drones to not be used
by
anyone for just about any mission you're
going to try and maintain
security and silence for as long as you
possibly can and then the biggest thing
you want to get on the enemy is surprise
let me pause it right here it's just
kind of not realistic at all
i guess they're trying to make things
look cool it always surprises me a
little bit because like i said it's the
best job in the world you don't really
need to do anything
to it to make it seem cool it is cool
it's awesome
so as far as like a random dude being
able to put his hands up to time this
sniper shot
it's dumb one of the things that makes
being in the seal teams difficult is a
lot of it is based around the water
if you're going to be wet all day guess
what else you're going to be you're
going to be cold and if you're in a cold
environment going in and being wet is
definitely something that's going to
affect you
we actually do use dry suits that keep
us dry as we go across
a wetsuit lets water in and it creates a
very small
layer of water between you and the ocean
that actually stays warm
a dry suit keeps you warm by keeping the
water completely out and you wear
warmer clothes underneath it but then
you have a problem of dealing with a dry
suit
i think one of the things that makes the
seals good is we have to deal with that
water
element all the time and so when we go
out and perform missions where there's
no water involved it always feels a lot
easier
freeze this frame when you go to sniper
school you actually build your own
that's called the ghillie suit what
they're wearing
when you go to sniper school you
actually build your own ghillie suit
there's parts of it that you can buy
but essentially they built those ghillie
suits themselves and they will adapt
that ghillie suit for different
environments so
if they're in a jungle environment
they'll make it more green if they're in
a desert environment they'll make it
more
sand colored and just depending on what
environment you're in you'll adapt your
ghillie suit to match that
the tap on the shoulder right there it
just means hey i'm the last guy
and when i tap you on the shoulder that
means you can leave that security
position
the problem with the hallway is there's
a lot of unknown space ahead of you
behind every one of those doors could be
a threat so what you have to do is you
have to maintain that security
if somebody just throws a hand grenade
down that hallway it's going to be a
problem if somebody sticks a weapon
around
one of those doors and starts shooting
it's going to be a problem so hallways
are definitely not somewhere we like to
hang out
the person that's looking forward has to
maintain that front security the person
that's behind them or maybe two people
back is actually controlling the flow of
the rest of the guys
i've got two squares coming out the back
door everyone's wearing a radio
certainly they'll utilize the radios if
you're out of line of sight of someone
else
also you just use verbal commands i mean
once the shooting is started we're not
surprising anyone so
we'll talk to each other especially
people that are in the vicinity
rather than having 30 people in the
element all talking on their radios
trying to explain things
it's better to have the groups that are
isolated together communicate just
verbally
if you have to communicate with someone
that you're not within line of sight
then you can get on the radio
this is american sniper
you said aqi has a sniper in the
olympics but iraq has a qualified
shooter in three games the film is
actually about chris kyle when i was
attacking your commander chris kyle was
in task and bruiser that was my task
unit when the film came out they
actually
had a screening for us down in coronado
seal team three that's when i saw the
movie a task unit
is two sealed platoons combined together
then with a small headquarters element
over it that's what a task unit is
well that's because my stuff is not iraq
in this particular case what they're
trying to show is that
the sniper's not gonna be alone he's
gonna have some kind of security with
them because if you're alone
and you're looking down your sniper
rifle then no one's covering your back
in this they're showing
chris with one other guy the reality of
the situation in ramadi
which is where chris was with me wasn't
just two guys or three guys
most of the time it was seven eight ten
fifteen twenty guys to
maintain a sniper position two things
that are kind of diametrically opposed
that are going on when you're
in a situation like this they all want
some kind of protection which is why
they're staying close to a wall which is
that makes sense however if you get too
bunched up
and a roadside bomb or an ied goes off a
booby trap goes off
obviously the closer you are together
the more people it's going to wound hey
there's times when you get punched up
and you might be with two or three
people to hold down a corner
but any military individual that's
watching that is not going to get a good
feeling seeing everyone bunched up like
that
i mean you couldn't see much of the
breach but essentially what a breach is
you put a big explosive breaching charge
which are especially made charges
that blow doors open you take a step
back and blow the charge out i mean
that's pretty normal
there's advantages to breaching as well
so when you detonate an explosive
breaching charge that's going to stun
the people in the room too so there's
some advantages
but there's also times where you want to
maintain you know
silence so there's advantages and
disadvantages to both
hey you don't mind if i'll roll with you
hey man let me see let's go by me
when we were in the battle ramadi every
operation we went out on we had army
navy air force marines with us all the
time i think this is representing a
marine corps element
they're calling the legend like 24
confirmed kills wow
lose count if the situation is going to
call for him to have like a really long
reach
be able to shoot very long distances
he's probably going to carry a
specialized
long-distance sniper weapon in an urban
environment like this
be pretty common just to carry one
weapon that you can use a little bit in
both environments
hey what's that me man reach her up tap
into your helmet like that which
actually
the shooting hand came off chris would
would not take his hand off his
trigger and be ready to shoot this right
here is breacher up i talked about
breachers earlier that means this door
is
locked or the decision has been made to
use some kind of explosive reaching
charge here
get down get down the ground right now
let me break this down a little bit
what's difficult about fighting in a
city is you have civilians that are
running around
intermixed with the enemy that you're
fighting one thing we have to remember
about the battle fallujah is there was
very strong warnings to everyone that
was civilians to get out of the city
and the people that stayed there were
considered hostile
why are you here what you're supposed to
be evacuating this area why are you
still here
if you've been told that everyone in the
city is going to be hostile then they're
probably taking the right approach
showing chris sitting there holding his
weapon on this little kid
chris wouldn't waste his time with that
he would move on to this adult
immediately what you're trying to do is
get control
that's what you're trying to do you
don't know what's happening when you
walk into a room you don't know what's
happening
things aren't as they seem so what
you're trying to do when you get into
rooms you're trying to get control of
the room i actually just mean get
control of the human beings that are in
there that could mean telling them to
get down on the ground and they're not
moving anymore cool
you have control now you need to
actually make sure that they don't have
any weapons
make sure they're not rigged with a
suicide vest or something like that so
that they can't attack you clearing
houses
what you're doing is trying to make sure
there's no bad guys in there if they're
in the streets you can take them out but
they're going to go into buildings
they're going to go into houses
it's a civilian populace that really
suffers and you know in ramadi where i
was
the civilians were the ones that were
suffering the worst because they were
catching it from both sides
we would have iraqi soldiers with us or
interpreters that would talk to the
family
and sometimes you sense some
uncomfortable situation
and all of a sudden you realize there's
a person in that house that wasn't from
that family well guess what they were an
insurgent they were a foreign fighter
and then we could catch them and take
them out
this is lone survivor where i see it we
got three options
one let him go hike up
probably be found in less than an hour
two we tie them up
hike out roll the dice they'll probably
be eaten by
wolves or freeze to death
three terminate the compromise
you know in the seal teams most of the
time everyone has the same general idea
of what we should do unless something is
just grievously
a bad call then someone might say hey
boss that's not a good call right now
but yeah for someone in a small group
like this they just talk to him and she
said this is not rare at all for a group
of seals to kind of discuss how we're
going to do something
now ultimately that decision rides on
the commander and whoever's in charge of
that element is the one that's going to
say
hey this was my decision and this is
what we did you can't as a leader
once you make a decision or once
consensus comes in
and then things go wrong you don't say
well you know that's what everyone
wanted to do you don't do that
you're the one with the final
decision-making power you can get
consensus you can take suggestions from
other people but ultimately when you're
the leader you're in charge you'll own
that decision that you make
we let him go 20 more will die next week
rules of engagement says we cannot touch
them
i understand and i don't care
[Music]
i care about you i care about you i care
about you
i care about you yeah you get a very
specific rules of engagement brief
you know what the rules are they could
be as specific as you're not allowed to
cuff
females or you're not allowed to enter a
mosque or
you're not allowed to go past a certain
line on a map there's going to be
parameters that you're allowed to
operate
within the big difference is in the seal
teams the
briefing is done by the members of the
platoon and everyone kind of briefs
their section so for instance
the point man will get up and explain
the route that we're going to take to
get to the target area
so that's all done by that point man
let's say the breach team is going to go
in and
do a breach on a on a wall or on a gate
the breach leader will take over that
part of the brief and say okay
once we get here bill you're going to be
there joe you're going to be here
breacher's going to come up set the
charge then we're going to take cover
back here so
everyone kind of individually briefs
their portion of the mission so
it's a collaborative effort the briefs
we try to keep the briefs to an hour
you know after an hour there shouldn't
be so much information that it takes
more than that and after an hour
guys hard drives are full we want them
to know the important things that we
want them to understand the flow of the
mission
and then once they have that that's it
it is a big deal to break the rules of
engagement but at the same time
rules of engagement are written in such
a way that if you think you need to do
something to protect
your troops or the mission then you can
pretty much do what you need to do to
make that happen
and so this is a tough decision to make
they want to execute this mission they
know they're going after a bad guy
that's killed
americans and at the same time they got
some people that they're suspect of but
they can't confirm
so it's a very tough decision to make
this is captain phillips
in this particular situation it's a
maritime environment
it's on boats and seals are the maritime
component
of u.s special operations so if there's
a strictly water operation like this
it's most likely going to be seals that
are going to be executing that operation
sir the pirates have just issued a
threat what's the translation
if he moves again shoot him that looks
like it's just the control room on a
navy ship that's what it looks like
there's a bunch of screens there
there's a lot of communications going on
in there there might be 10 or 15 people
that are in there observing what's going
on and communicating with each other
that's one of the things that we do all
the time when we're training is we
shoot what we call hostage scenarios so
they'll put
a friendly target in front of a
non-friendly target
and we'll have to go in and shoot the
bad guy without shooting the good guy my
task unit conducted one
hostage rescue during our deployment to
ramadi where we went and rescued a 15 or
16 year old kid
that had been kidnapped by insurgents
and was being held for ransom rescued
that kid and it was successful
something that we trained for it doesn't
happen very often hostage rescues are
very challenging situations because if
you know a building's filled with bad
guys well then you can be
very liberal in how you employ your
weapon systems if you're going against
a target where you know there's
friendlies there like a hostage then you
have to be
much more discriminatory in how you
engage the enemy
alpha and charlie red we are three red
this time i am a lightbulb this is the
negotiator if you harm the hostage we do
not have a deal
i've never heard of a negotiation going
down in a military scenario
because we're assuming that the people
that have the hostages are hostile
and what they need to do is die you know
the the seals that conducted this
operation are some of the best guys in
the entire world
and when they're going to take a shot
they're going to be ready to take that
shot
and i don't know about this coordination
system if they used it
awesome but if they didn't it wouldn't
matter these guys are going to get the
job done
roger stop the toe
execute
generally decentralized command is what
we're dealing with
so in that case where the snipers are
co-located like that they'd probably be
just communicating amongst themselves
you want your subordinate teams when
they launch you want them to have the
green light to go when things are ready
so that's a little bit micromanaged but
i don't know how it unfolded exactly
for real we do know one thing they
rescued that guy and killed the bad guys
so credit a lot of my vocabulary
is infected because i was in the seal
teams my whole adult life i mean
occasionally i'll get a funny look if i
say
check for instance that's one where if
you tell me something i might say back
to you
check that means i understand and i'm
good with what you're saying
no factor which is you tell me that
something's going on i might look at you
and say no factor which means i got this
and those are good ones because
they're used a lot i mean you can use a
lot in everyday life you know if someone
says oh no
there's you know traffic on the highway
no factor i'll take the side roads
like just normal stuff like that but
yeah there's a ton of things that we say
in the
in the military it's just the way it is
you go to any organization they're gonna
have their own little words that they
use
that's just the way i talk now
this is zero dark 30.
helicopters are definitely one of the
most common modes of transportation
but again it varies from place to place
when i was in the battle ramadi the
couple times that they did fly over the
city
when we were there they got shot at
heavily even to extract a wounded guy
we'd have to get him
out of the city into one of the secure
bases to get someone in a helicopter
even for fire support you know on in the
battle romani fire support was almost
all tanks and tankers
so god bless those guys for what they
did but in a situation like this they're
traveling long distances
in afghanistan they used helicopters all
the time
dogs are are pretty common their senses
that they have what they can do
to be blunt about it you can put them in
situations where you wouldn't want to
risk the life of a human being they use
them for sniffing for explosives as well
they're great assets to have
yeah it looks like they're just naming
what those helicopters are called and
that's normal
different aircraft will have different
call signs in this case they're
prince52 and prince51 i think what
they're trying to represent
is different phase lines of an operation
so in other words
as you move in towards a target you'll
have different
marks when you get past those marks
you'll call them up the chain of command
so everyone knows hey we're at phase
line alpha phase line bravo so
everyone's kind of
aware of where the mission is as it
takes place
hey justin what are you listening to
tony robbins
tony robbins really used to listen to it
i got plans for after this
it looks like he's got some noise
cancelling headsets over his
iphone so he'd probably be able to pull
it off crank up the volume
that's just the border between
afghanistan and pakistan
guaranteed to have a face line at that
border we just crossed the border now
entering pakistan
pakistani comes no chatter even though
they've crossed into
pakistani land they're not hearing any
communication
from anyone so they're saying hey look
we've
gone into pakistan but no one's talking
about it which is a positive sign
their night vision it looks like in all
these sometimes there's some more
advanced goggles that have
thermo as well but from what i can see
in these pictures it just looks like
regular night vision yeah some of those
are just even more advanced
night vision goggles that give you a
better field of view people get adapted
to them
it takes you know a couple hours of
walking around and you're you're adapted
to them if you come into a bright room
and it bleeds out your
night vision raise your head a little
bit and you can look underneath your
night vision it's not that big of a deal
or you can just flip them up you go into
a dark room you can just kind of knock
your head forward a little bit and those
night vision will slip back down so
everyone finds their own little
techniques on on how they're going to do
it
30 seconds
yeah basically there's a big thick rope
grab hold of that rope and you slide
down
like a fireman going down a fireman's
pole pretty straightforward stay
tight stay close when the bird sets down
and takes off you want your group to be
assembled pretty closely until you start
to move towards the target
i'd say one of the big misconceptions
that people have
of people that are in the seal teams is
that they're
some kind of superhuman individuals you
got to remember that
seals are just people and they train
really hard
work really hard to try and be good at
our jobs but
they're still people and they're not
just terminated robots we watch a bunch
of movies of these
different operations or these fictitious
operations but we got to remember that
the seals just like every other branch
of the service has taken massive
casualties
not only in our history but in these
recent wars so
even though it might look cool you got
to remember that there's been real
sacrifices made
not just by the seals themselves not
just by the marines in the army
and the air force but the families that
are at home as well that suffer those
losses and
live with those for the rest of their
lives we always have to remember what
the real sacrifices are
that was my breakdown thanks for
watching